hey rich can you hear me yeah how you
doing man good good um so i wanted to
get your
uh kind of story on
where you were at where you when you
decided you needed to make the switch
over to going on trt
and if you have a
um
like a guideline or something like that
for somebody that wants to do that yeah
so let me start this segment by telling
you a story so i was at my buddy jason
gaynor's event mastermind talks in 2009
and 10 i think i did it back to back and
i was talking to
a guy at lunch
tony square jawed
very energetic older than me uh i had
done an off-road rally with him a few
years before and he looked really good
and i said him i go tone i go what's
going on man you're full of energy
you're looking good you're jacked you
got you know pipes and everything i'm
like you know what's up he's probably
about 44 at the time he goes
testosterone therapy right i got hooked
up with the doctor blah blah blah felt
great you know like everything's working
really well now
okay so i made a mental note you know
like i was in my late 30s at that time
and
i was familiar with anabolics you know i
got the world anabolic review in 1996
when i was thinking about taking
testosterone when i was in my 20s i
never took it but um yeah so i was
familiar and
when the time came when i was going to
the gym and i'm like i'm lacking energy
i'm lacking productivity i'm lacking
focus
morning wood is not as frequent anymore
um i'm not able to maintain muscle mass
i'm losing muscle mass
i'm i'm holding on to more body fat i
don't have motivation to do like an hour
workout an hour half workout i'd go in
there for like 20 minutes and just do
some [ __ ] calf exercises and that
was it and leave sort of thing that's
when i was like huh maybe i should go
check my blood labs and you know i paid
you know
out of pocket some money i signed up for
a a a longevity clinic it was kind of
like advertised as a
um
like longevity sort of health clinic you
know for older people
um middle-aged older people and um yeah
i got my blood labs and you know kind of
started from from there and we tried to
make some tweaks to do it naturally for
one or two cycles of blood labs
and i really knew why i went in there
i'm like just give me the [ __ ]
testosterone but the guy's like going
through all the exercises to cross his
teeth and dot his eyes and make sure
that he's not gonna get in trouble you
know with his medical license sort of
thing i'm like just give me the tea
buddy right you know so after about a
couple cycles of labs i'm like i don't
see much changing doc like let's just
apply the t sort of thing and that's
where it started for me that was about
five years ago
okay and where would you recommend
somebody else
kind of start along that path you're
gonna have to ask around man yeah
is it based on like
no it's based on
on on feel so
yeah if you go to a medical clinic and
you're paying them for the service and
they're like well it says you're in
normal range travis but
but then you just tell the guy look
i don't make wake up with morning wood
like i did before i'm not interested in
sex like i was before i'm not productive
as i was before i'm not as muscular and
strong and i'm getting fatter as i was
before
like something is is not right here
right
that's how that's how you turn up the
volume on something like that some
places just issue like a cookie cutter
protocol though like you call them up
where do you live in the states or in
canada i live in the states i'm actually
a chiropractor so
okay so i mean like you'll you'll get a
lot of cookie cutter clinics where it's
like 200 milligrams of testosterone they
give you an ai they tell you like you
know your injection frequency is once a
week and it's like the standard [ __ ]
right
so that'll get some guys some results
and you'll feel awesome for the first
three or four weeks because your levels
like spike huge right um but you have to
be able to manage it over the long term
right so
if you're a chiropractor and you're
already medically trained then you kind
of know what kind of questions to ask
and you know who to rely on yeah
so find a a clinic that's going to be
interested in like treating your
symptoms and not just like
where i get that patient interaction
yeah well you're gonna have to ask them
yeah like you're gonna have to ask them
how how they work if it's a if it's a
telemedicine clinic if it's a clinic
that you have to walk into sort of thing
and meet with a guy
um some have an annual fee some have a
monthly fee some pays you visit like
with my guy i just pay him for every
doctor's visit
um
you know the scripts you pay at the
pharmacy downstairs sort of thing
so
it's not hard to get especially if
you're older and
again they've got like a full
like checklist of everything that they
have to go through right
focus productivity libido you know
erection quality blah blah blah all that
stuff and it's like if you're starting
to show deficiencies
and you're not feeling optimized in
those areas they're like okay travis we
can give you some of this stuff over
here what do you want to cream you want
an injection you want a pellet
so on that you usually do
injections right i would recommend doing
injections if you're going to go
therapeutic testosterone because pellets
suck you can get infections because they
have to it's minor surgery right um
they're not steady and you have to
constantly get them done
sublingual tablets
you're probably going to pass through
the liver because it's got to go through
your
digestive tract um whatever's not
absorbed you know just under your tongue
so it's not the greatest
uh compounded creams are very expensive
and they're not that effective it gets
in your clothing gets in your pets gets
on your wife your girlfriend your kids
whatever
um
there's there's one combatted cream um
that my buddy jay recommends where you
basically have to keep your nut sack
shaved and they have a compounded gel
which is 200 milligrams per milliliter
you get out of the shower click click
you put it on your uh balls you kind of
let it uh you know brush your teeth do
your hair whatever you got to do
five ten minutes later you know you
throw your clothes on and what's
absorbed needs to get in that's the only
effective cream that i've heard of and
jay swears by it now but
injections are
the cheapest the easiest to modify like
if you want a little bit more draw a
little bit more in the vial if your
levels are too high take some out right
there's no click click there's no
pellets you know that they have to
stitching or anything like that
so that's the way that i would go that's
the way that i would recommend going
anyway
cool
thanks a lot yeah man no problem hey
guys i really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you